das nachfolgende video soll eigentlich
nur eine parodie sein ihm ist
aufgefallen
ich habe erst zwei videos mit über einer
million views kann doch nicht sein oder
ich glaube ich habe da eine idee
willkommen beim ein video
heute kommt das richtig heute kommt was
wir waren heute zusammen mit euch in
1000 fucking tampons nimmt das video
nicht einschalten sollen oder paroli
seien viel spaß wenn es witzig findet
das daumen nach oben
mehr will ich gar nicht sagen zu
entscheiden
leute kurzen update noch gerade fühlt
sich die badewanne automatisch ich bin
hier raus noch mit juri und die war
wollten wir noch schnell sage ich hab
das gestern wie du schon gesagt dass ein
bisschen untergang weiß voll am ende war
julian auch ein youtube channel der ist
ganz oben oder irgendwo in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und erzählt weiter
also ich hab alex 24 stunden lang
geprägt und wer muss überlegt so ist es
echt mega wichtig geworden ich hab mich
24 stunden genervt direkt nachdem wir
angekommen sind habe hindurchgeht
geprägt ich bin bei ihm rein gelaufen
ist das habe ich alles in einem video
zusammengefasst
das haben wir uns überlegt was überlegt
haben uns überlegt wenn juli also der
hatten nicht so lange mit youtube
angefangen weil er die 8000 abonnenten
hat inter das video hoch also lohnt sich
auf jeden fall hin zu abonnieren jetzt
viel spaß mit dem steht dahinter
2000 jahre später
soweit sich gestern solche mit ihren
kopf ich glaube die badewanne ist
eigentlich gemacht dass man darin
könnten die sich direkt auf blasen
2001 war ich mich voll eklig
diese genieße es total
zur ganzen kaufen
die sägen halle auf dem boden das aus
es ist mein kreativstes video auch im
herzen kanal
es war ein sinnvolles video
und mal alles so was gab's noch nie
erlebt man champagner schon mal die
hauptstadt ungewiss geworden
es ist echt eine schande meinte das
knappe million das klappt stehen leute
zur seite und althaus bayerisch ich
wollte es nicht so richtig witzig
darstellen so jetzt habe ich eigentlich
so ein komplettes gleichen moment wieder
langenau dass man ferrostaal leute keine
ahnung letzte tropfen auf jeden fall was
mit dem video wenn es lustig verlassen
nach oben da würd mich sehr freuen
das sollte eigentlich wollte das volk
wird sich darstellen habe ich das bisher
geschafft nehmen doch schon am start
schon willst sie spaß haben
egal ob auch video morgen kommt mega
boni nicht vergessen wir sehen uns
morgen
schließlich rufen